[Musique]
des enfants de partout à travers le
monde s'amuse depuis 25 ans avec ce
produit inventé au québec mais micheline
des liens elle ne s'amuse plus du tout
et veut obtenir justice pourquoi j'ai
inventé ce projet sur ce marché sa peau
des loges de ce fait avoir
la journaliste josée dupuis et la
réalisatrice johanne demers nous raconte
ce soir l'histoire de cette mère
monoparentale qui a créé dans sa cuisine
la célèbre pâte à modeler tutti frutti
elle ne reçoit plus un sou pourtant son
contrat lui promettait de toucher des
redevances temps que la compagnie allait
fabriquer et commercialiser la pâte à
modeler que tu te ramasses 25 imputant
puis que tu est endetté lajus clown
micheline des biens était loin de se
douter qu'elle finira un jour derrière
les portes closes d'un cabinet d'avocat
a livré la bataille de sa vie
[Musique]
nous sommes au début des années 90
michel desbiens vit de l'aide sociale
avec deux petites filles à nourrir la
nécessité étant la mère de l'invention
une idée surgit alors qu'elle regarde
ses enfants jouer avec de la pâte à
modeler commercial et en ouvrira le
conteneur sûr je regardais le jambon du
ailleurs et dont 20 cents
bon je trouve et quelle étiquette baisse
des faisons un peu plus tôt possible
le lendemain avec ses chants conclu puis
c'est insulter le g10 les enfants jouent
avec son logisticien pas de bon sens
le ca a fait joseph lau mon invention
je veux inventer la mère porte à modeler
au monde inventé de la pâte à modeler
peut sembler banal combien de parents en
ont fabriqué pour leurs enfants
mais micheline desbiens a l'ambition de
faire une pâte naturel non toxique et
biodégradable coloré qui ne sèche pas ne
sait n'y est pas et sent bon les fruits
elle travaille jour et nuit
les essais les erreurs se succèdent
vous voyez aller trop collant j'avais de
la misère à rejoindre les boucles de
france saf et granollers noté à -10 est
accolée à changer de couleur feu justin
en garde
c'est complètement ridicule le mon
enfance et puis à chaque fois il ya
quelqu'un qui me dit hey tu devrais
essayer telle affaire tal afar jeudi ben
oui c'est vrai
l'une de ces personnes ces marques
germes est un ingénieur chimiste
aujourd'hui à la retraite
cet homme a toujours cru en elle je
l'avais aidé surtout ce côté produits
non callens
j'avais trouvé un produit c'est à du
plus élégant
on essayait plusieurs vagues ça
fonctionne et puis
lui-même ya toutes sortes d'ingrédients
l'outil pour pâques accueille pourquoi
qu'attache pas casser mes impôts pour
caceres jsk lieu la dernière les moins
collante
oui j'ai fait pas loin de 600 recettes
comme un qui était sur mon contrat
quand de mélanger pire si sa foi à bron
aussi l'allemagne et je me serais à
bosser avec une bursite pour ses
performances
comment tu la trouves il faut maintenant
un brevet pour protéger la recette de
cet évent crise dans l'âme mais
enregistré un brevet ça coûte 10 où il
ya personne qui voulait m'aider mais
même le bien-être social
ils voulaient paumé et des gouvernements
n'ont plus fait que finalement je
traverse la chine voisine qui gardait
mes enfants de temps en temps qu'il fait
que je dis rien je dis belge préparant
mon brevet il manque 2515 je trouvais
qu'elle avait du courage
une femme seule avec ses enfants puis
est vraiment déterminée un travail est
fort c'est vrai que le soir souvent à se
coucher tard à douvres ada et son mari
n'ont pas hésité un instant et lui
prêtent les 2500 $ nécessaires pour
faire breveter son invention
je trouvais que pour quelqu'un qui veut
peut-être là pas la ville la plus facile
financièrement elle avait quand même
pris à
un projet assez difficile pour le rendre
du début jusqu'à la fin
le brevet est enregistré au canada et
aux états unis
il faut maintenant la fabriquer et la
vendre cette fameuse pâte à modeler
micheline des biens va frapper à
plusieurs portes sans succès jusqu'au
jour où la compagnie de jouets beau jeu
et son président georges garraud
démontrent un intérêt certain
le serbe war date de number one a été un
week end le week end
la compagnie a fait waouh t'es c'est ça
faisait quelques années qu'ils
cherchaient avoir un produit plus a
lancé sur la chaîne internationale
compagnie familiale c'était mon rêve
d'avoir une compagnie québécoise famille
familiale société la cerise sont des
jeux la bonne compagnie québécoise pour
faire travailler les gens dans une
émission diffusée en 2015 sur canal z
georges gard ou propriétaire à l'époque
de bons jeux se plaît à raconter
l'histoire de cette femme déterminée
comme des biens ok et l'adobe étaient
bonnes au pav antal avec deux pays et
non cadres de vu la texture élevant son
brevet et c'est tous les droits à vos
jeux le contrat qu'elle signe lui assure
des redevances sur les ventes de la pâte
à modeler et cela tant et aussi
longtemps que la compagnie va fabriquer
et commercialiser ce produit désormais
connue sous la marque tutti frutti
le succès est immédiat
la pâte à modeler récolte entre autres
les meilleures critiques du magazine
protégez-vous et connaît un succès
monstre à la foire du jouet de new york
elle remporte le titre de meilleur
joueur canadien et américain
tutti frutti est présente dans les
écoles et garderies
il est un peu comme sadate et oui c'est
dans des années 90 michel desbiens
multiplie les entrevues
je vous la présente tout de suite touché
des biens aux gens que je viens de
manger l'histoire de cette mère de
famille monoparentale ravi les médias
que je sois un jour pouvoir de zine
stand n 2 en baisse et victoire c'est
waou j'ai réussi la petite fille de
chapleau l'outil majeur secondaire
simple que j'ai fait ça affiche nôtre
c'est mon rêve se réaliser en fait tout
ça non celle pour prendre le marché de
la pâte à modeler puis je relevais un
jaguar pendant 17 ans micheline des
biens reçoit en moyenne 50 mille dollars
par année en redevances ce revenu lui
permet de rester à la maison pour élever
ses filles et de ne plus s'inquiéter
pour l'avenir mais elle ne roulera
jamais en jaguar en 2009
le beau conte de fées préfet abruptement
[Musique]
j'ai tellement de peine déçu franche et
enragé par boulot chérubin des périodes
très longues longtemps je sais pourquoi
j'ai inventé ce projet mis sur ce marché
sa peau d'âne aux cheveux se fait avoir
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2009
la compagnie beau jeu éprouvent des
ennuis financiers et se place sous la
protection de la loi sur la faillite et
l'insolvabilité et ne prévient pas
madame des biens qu'il apprend par les
médias son avocat doit se battre pour
l'inscrire sur la liste des créanciers
elles cessent de recevoir ces redevances
je me sentais comme
rien pas de clôture avec aucune
considération aucun respect les actifs
de beaux jeux sont vendus à une
compagnie à numéro qui devient bourges 2
les deux nouveaux actionnaires sont
sabrina et laurence garot les filles de
georges barau un an plus tard georges
garraud lui même reprend les rênes de
beaujeu 2 la nouvelle compagnie continue
toujours de produire et de vendre la
pâte à modeler tutti frutti et ne se
sent pas du tout lié par le contrat de
madame des biens fait que fait que ce
contrôle au 1 mai 2009 y ont disparu
pour lui pour cet homme d'affaires
disparu il voulait plus respecter la
convention
pourtant le contrat que madame des biens
signé en 1993 est très clair tenter
aussi longtemps qu'une compagnie produit
la pâte à modeler tutti frutti micheline
des biens doit recevoir ces redevances
danielle gagnaux et professeur à la
faculté de droit de l'université laval
nous avons voulu avoir la vie de ce
spécialiste des contrats le contrôle
suis nécessairement à partir du moment
où vous achetez le un contrat
d'exploitation de d'une invention vous
ne pouvez pas échapper aux obligations
liées aux redevances à payer
pendant que la pâte à modeler tutti
frutti fait le bonheur de milliers
d'enfants l'envers du décor lui est
beaucoup moins rose
madame des biens est en congé de maladie
et une bataille juridique s'annonce
c'est micheline des biens qui remporte
la première manche en 2014 la cour
supérieure une bonne game corps 71,58
548 doite à madame des biens des
redevances totalisant 85 mille 56
dollars et 25 le tribunal ordonnera le
versement de cette somme
bon jeu deux portes la cause en appel
nouvelle victoire pour madame des biens
la cour d'appel tranche également en sa
faveur
la cour rejette l'appel condamne 71,58
548 canada inc api à micheline débit à
85000 56 de l'entreprise qui avait
acquis les droits d'exploitation était
finalement opéré par les mêmes personnes
sous des noms différents avec les filles
de monsieur garrot avec monsieur biya
vont en sous main et que cela les rangs
des responsables
tout comme s'il représentait le premier
acquéreur de l'invention ses traits
c'est très valorisant aussi de voir que
finalement les les juges reconnaissent
mais royauté mais là vous avez ces deux
jugements rares saveur mais ça ça donne
mais en tenant sa donne auriez le jeu
court encore après mon argent car avant
même que ne tombe la décision de la cour
d'appel
beaujeu 2 est insolvable les coffres
sont vides
la compagnie a vendu le restant de ses
actifs à une nouvelle compagnie beau jeu
inc dirigée par olivier maillot bouge 2
fera éventuellement failli
[Applaudissements]
le nouvel administrateur s'engage à
rembourser tous les créanciers parmi
lesquels on retrouve les pouces
la mère et le frère de georges garrot
pour micheline des biens monsieur
mailloux dit avoir laissé à georges
barau un montant de 120 mille dollars
pour qu'il puisse faire face à ses
responsabilités en vue d'un éventuel
jugement de la cour d'appel
madame des biens n'a jamais vu la
couleur de cet argent
michel desbiens et son avocat attaque
la transaction entre beau jeu 2 et beau
jeu inc qu'il juge frauduleuse
il allègue que georges garraud sa fille
sabrina et olivier mailloux ont agi de
concert pour priver l'inventrice de ses
redevances pour lesquels beau jeu d'eux
a été condamné
la relation entre ces individus est au
coeur du nouveau litige
nous avons voulu savoir ce qu'il en est
une de nos équipes s'est rendu au salon
du jouet de drummondville au kiosque de
beau jeu elle est accueillie par nul
autre que georges garraud qui utilise
avec empressement l'histoire de madame
des biens comme argument de vente que la
madame qui a 21 ans et est fait à base
d'éléments naturels cette eau des trucs
à trouver dans ce qu'ils aiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'association québécoise de l'industrie
du jouet tient sa foire annuelle
une occasion pour les compagnies de
rencontrer les détaillants l'un des plus
gros kiosques et celui de beaujeu
troisième mouture
mais sur place on retrouve les mêmes
joueurs
sabrina garraud directrice de la
recherche et du développement et à ses
côtés son père georges carreau
nous avons rencontré ce dernier en
caméra cachée il vante à notre
collaborateur la marque tutti frutti
célibataire voulait d'abord je fais tous
les 20 ou le phénomène qui s'est
accompagné ces mots je suis j'ai vendu
ma compagne laquelle compagnie ah bon je
débats au dessus à des maux actuels
c'est un beau geste ses bourgeons et aux
gens qui ont racheté bon jeu il est
pourri si aujourd'hui pose c'est parce
que des salons ton est beaucoup moins
quand il m'a demandé à me gonfler je
suis très attaché selon le propriétaire
de bons jeux inc olivier mailloux change
garraud est toujours à l'emploi de la
compagnie vous n'entendez ici lors de sa
comparution en cour supérieure en
février 2010 est dans la nouvelle
bataille qui l'oppose à michel desbiens
expérience me suis garé où travaillent
encore pour la compagnie qui fait il
s'occupe de fardha consultations au
niveau des ventes internationales
le consultant en ventes internationales
de beau jeu est en mission aujourd'hui à
drummondville de personnes les vendeurs
qu'est-ce que convient donc d'être au
touriste parce que les gars
alors oui bonjour ne se gare ou s'il
vous plaît nous avons joint au téléphone
georges garraud qui n'a pas voulu nous
accorder d'entrevue à la caméra
contrairement à ce qu'il dit en caméra
cachée mais ce gars on ne semble pas
très au courant du dossier
alors qu'il est poursuivi
personnellement dans ce litige
vous dites ça semble être en cours vous
savez pas c'est encore ou pas c'est donc
vous savez pas c'est toujours en cours
je le fais parce que dans la cour du
tout je ne les ai pas demandé à savoir
si tu es toujours en cours bien il
faudrait contacter l'avocat de l'autre
côté déco vraiment de me regarde de peau
vraiment maintenant j'ai vendu je les
fais pas à ma fille sabrina est un
partenaire auquel olivier laloux nous
avons contacté sa fille sabrina
oui bonjour sabrina carreau cette
dernière a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue en raison du litige en cours
êtes une des propriétaires de beau jeu
est propriétaire madame pas encore le
cas mais je peux pas je ne pouvais
demander de les écouter j'aurai le droit
joue donnerait des informations je peux
pas en pariant d'akono dif et tout le
monde est faite demain au fait que l'on
n'a pas le droit en parler c'est encore
super bowl et je veux pas porter
atteinte ni à madany bien lui a beau
joueur donc je ne peux pas à pareille
fête en cours mais de me dire en sonnant
brit air
merci à monsieur bayrou d'avoir accepté
nous donner une entrevue
olivier maillot lui a accepté de nous
rencontrer parce qu'il juge que sa
réputation est en jeu car ton attaque
mon intégrité et qu'on me dépose une
poursuite en employant des mots fraude
je vous dirais que je sens que ma
réputation hystérie c'est pour ça que tu
es si aujourd'hui mais ce gars on se dit
qu'ils avaient vendu sa compagnie à sa
fille sabrina est un partenaire
d'affaires
monsieur gao au rendu des actifs à moi
et sa fille
en fait je peux acheter deux compagnies
j'ai acheté des actifs si je vais chez
vous que j'achète votre télé j'achète
votre divers enjeux pas acheter votre
maison que la maison monsieur gare où je
la voulais pas sa fille est un
partenaire minoritaire dans l'entreprise
monsieur mailloux soutient avoir besoin
de georges garraud et de ses 40 ans
d'expérience dans le domaine du jouet je
m'assois de prendre les meilleures
personnes pour but c'est monsieur garou
est l'une de ses meilleures personnes
pour parler du produit aux gens que je
n'irai pas que monsieur guy roux une
certaine connaissance de mes produits
effective monsieur garraud demeure très
présent au sein de la compagnie
quand nous l'avons joint il rentrait du
salon du jouet de toronto préparait
celui de new york et s'apprêtaient à
s'envoler vers la chine pour participer
à la foire du jouet de hong kong avec sa
fille
je garde monsieur gayraud pour les
actifs qui m'apporte en ce moment c'est
pau une relation à long terme que jouer
monsieur vient où j'avais un contrat de
deux ans avec monsieur gare aux
contrevenants extension et de six mois
selon monsieur mailloux beau jeu inc se
porte bien
de son côté madame des billets affirme
que la nouvelle compagnie exploitent
illégalement sa pâte à modeler l1 clame
de nouvelles redevances en plus de
celles qu'ils ont été accordés par la
cour
georges gard on mentionne à notre
collaborateur que le contrat de
redevances n'existe plus qu'ils avaient
une durée limitée il ne semble pas se
rappeler des deux jugements en faveur de
madame des biens
une quarantaine en chine et après ça
ltd compris le moment sympa le monde se
connaît et on se mit à vue est très
fière on a
nous avons soumis le contrat au
professeur florian martin bariteau de
l'université d'ottawa un spécialiste des
brevets le contrat certes porté trouver
son origine dans la cession du brevet de
madame desbiens a beau jeu mais le
contraire est rédigée de telle sorte que
les redevances devaient être payés à
madame des biens que le brevet soit
toujours valide ou non valide
le contrat dit que c'est tant que cette
cette recette cette invention est
exploité par la compagnie mais voilà en
rachetant les actifs de l'ancienne
compagnie olivier mailloux a exclu le
contrat de madame des biens il a exclu
selon lui pour une raison toute simple
mais qui va provoquer tout un revirement
dans cette bataille judiciaire
je ne produis pas la recette de madame
libye j'ai donné accès aux documents qui
le projet des expertises indépendantes
qui disent que je produis une recette
qui a rien à voir avec la cia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon jeu il clame aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
produit plus la pâte à modeler de madame
des biens au salon du jouet georges
garraud explique à notre collaborateur
que dès les tout débuts lui même
souhaité modifier la recette du moins
l'améliorer compagnie nous comme on
connaissait beaucoup là bas qu'à moitié
on adapte et on ne dit pas attendez pas
à point elle donne à qui toutes les
couleurs deviennent bleues on a engagé
des chercheurs et on a des chimistes qui
aident à gagner de tota déchets déchets
dont je regardais canada monsieur
garraud semble oublier le coup de foudre
qui l'a eue pour l'invention de madame
des biens de quoi on était d'actifs
cotisent fantasmes dominique tisdale a
travaillé chez beau jeu dans les années
90 on la voit ici sur ces images d
archives a brouillé sa peau sa recette
géant n'était là j'étais l'autre total
jamais bruni sa recette
puis on a fait des tests avec avec
madame des biens pour essayer de kaka on
la faisait sécher puis après tu en
parles à la réhydrater tout ça
fonctionnait toi tu sais c'est en place
une pâte à modeler
superbe avec la recette à hamish les ses
bananes tisdale qui faisait office de
chimistes de chez vos jeux elle avait à
peine 20 ans et aucun diplôme j'étais
toute seule mon petit chaudron est
heureux je faisais des petites boules de
test puis jamais eu d'ingénieur chimiste
qui sont venus voir non chimie est non
non c'est si c'était moi le chimiste qui
n'avait jamais fait ça avant
ils nous ont demandé les patrons nous
ont demandé de trouver dorothée
ingrédients 100% naturel pour que la
personne reste naturel mais pour
remplacer les produits et est breveté ok
pour pouvoir mettre la recette à leur
nom ok c'est ça pour pouvoir dans le
fond pour forte hausse et micheline vous
avez senti ça on l'a pas sentie on le
savait ils l'ont dit qu'est ce qu'ils
ont dit mais n'est tout simplement so2
et qui veulent plus payer de royautés
micheline si la compagnie n'a pas réussi
à changer un seul ingrédient
pourquoi alors la modifier 25 ans plus
tard les raisons seraient multiples on
ne m'écoute celle des quotas thomert et
pc tools pâte à modeler dans l'est du
parc comme les deux époux avant d'enfin
par carat chez moi aussi la seule la cei
comme on l'a fait pour les écoles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du sel il y en avait au départ pour que
les enfants ne la mangent pas mais
surtout pour empêcher que la pâte à
modeler ne moisissent avec toute la
réglementation quelque 800 et comme on
l'a 20 nous dans différents pays
il fallait rapporter les normes
canadiennes ok les rencontres les normes
américaines l'homme européennes sont des
pays arabes
pourtant dès le départ en 1993 tutti
frutti a été vendu dans de nombreux pays
la compagnie dès le début un talent et
ce partout partout en europe en asie en
grinçant nostre sont allés partout non
mais la porte a modelé par tous et selon
le représentant de beau jeu la compagnie
s'apprête maintenant à lancer une pâte à
modeler sans gluten avec bientôt
fillon sans guitare chant et coloris et
conte écolo faire du bien aux certifiés
ouais comme
bio comme la carotte bio et les maillots
exactement les guetteurs autant de
madame tisdale la compagnie avait aussi
tenté l'expérience
c'est ce qui faisait les la cité de la
plastique donc sans gluten si ce qui
faisait que la personne de venir liquide
pour l'actuel propriétaire olivier
mailloux il n'y a qu'une seule raison
qui justifie le changement de recettes
économiquement ce n'était pas rentable
de produire la recette de madame v bien
sous aucun angle mais mais pourquoi
c'est trop cher un trauma des secrets
commerciaux
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
certains ingrédients de la recette de
madame n'ont jamais été achetées dans ma
compagne donc été changées avant que
vous preniez la recette spécule repose
sur la date de changement de recettes ça
fait partie du dos il court
olivier mailloux nous a permis de
consulter le rapport d'expertisé que
beau jeu inc a déposé en cour pour des
raisons de confidentialité
nous ne pouvons en dévoiler le contenu
intégral il ne s'agit pas d'une analyse
chimique en bonne et due forme mais
d'une liste d'ingrédients soumis par la
compagnie deux ingrédients de la recette
originale de madame des biens ont été
remplacés dans le camp des billets on
est à la recherche d'un laboratoire qui
pourra analyser les ingrédients un
processus coûteux pour eux la base de la
recette est la même si boeing affirme ne
plus produire la même recette
son représentant des ventes continue
comme on l'a vu de se servir de
l'histoire de madame des biens nous
montrons à olivier mailloux les images
que nous avons capté au salon du jouet
que la madame kenza descendance et est
fait à base d'éléments naturels cette
eau des trucs à trouver dans ses
cuisines longue et il semble qu'on voit
ceux qui s'en sert beaucoup de jeu car
j'ai mes vous reconnaissez qu'il ya
peut-être pas d'affaires absolument pas
d'accord il ya des raisons pour que
monsieur yao épaules à la tête d'une
compagnie de joie en ce moment il ya des
raisons pourquoi c'est moi qui lui aux
pannes
nous nous sommes rendus dans un des
magasins franc jeu propriété du clan
garraud l'histoire de madame des biens
la hausse y est évoqué rapidement et est
associé au succès de la marque tutti
frutti
si la recette a changé les employés eux
ne semblent pas au courant et le
consommateur
encore moins tout flotter c'est la seule
afin qu'ils étaient conçus ou québec lé
dans la pâte dans la plasticine
sereinement le famille une vingtaine
d'années de ce qu'ils voyaient souvent
si c'est vraiment ça fait 25 ans forcé
au moins tout et pour tout cinq royal je
passe sur cette femme qui avait deux
familles c'est la droite millionnaire
samedi
c'est ce que le sommet qui avait fait
son argent au premier coup d'oeil il
apparaît en tout cas pour le moins
surprenant que après des années
d'exploitation de la même pâte à modeler
qui est toujours vendue est bien connu
dans le public on aurait tout à coup
découvert une nouvelle recette tout en
continuant à vendre le même produit et
qui ferait que ne serait plus lié par le
premier contrat avec celles qui ont
inventé le produit en question
tout cela va devoir être démontrée en
cours évidemment parce que au départ il
semblerait que des redevances plus être
rattaché à la vente d'un produit qui en
apparence ne pas changer
neuf ans d'une lutte qui s'éternise
michel desbiens 10 de sa rente
d'invalidité sans aucun autre revenu
son avocat la défend à titre gracieux en
attendant un pourcentage si un jour le
conflit se règle je touchais pas juste
là car des enfants
j'ai touché le cas de tout le monde puis
d'en voir aujourd'hui
[Musique]
non sans votre fatigue puis votre fait
il de me voir aujourd'hui à me battre
pour protéger mes droits je veux juste
qu'ils me paye c'est juste qu'ils
respectent la control qui me paye moldus
[Musique]
olivier maillot lui estime en avoir fait
assez pour madame des biens même si cet
argent comme on l'a vu ne lui est jamais
parvenu j'ai rajouté 120 mille dollars
dans la société de monsieur garrot pour
m'assurer que cette société l'ol toutes
les ressources financières pour faire
face à ses obligations pour pop
personnes soit l'elysée dans la
transaction je faisais donc là vous
parlez madame des bières la femme
d'affaires mme adam deby exactement là
qui la femme de voir avec la pac et la
femme d'affaires madame des biens oui ok
c'est une femme d'affaires
pour moi quelqu'un qui inquiète cycle de
800 à 1000 $ dans ces vies qui russes
estoniens contre perpétuelle jeudi à
négocier son avis code et travaillent
gratuitement pour elle de défendre sa
cause c'est pour ça à ta je pense que
c'est un truc heureuse femme d'affaires
des victimes
[Musique]
cette lutte sans fin n'est pas sans
rappeler celle de claude robinson et de
ses droits d'auteur qui s'est rendue
jusqu'en cour suprême
cet exemple le lot de claude robinson
peut être transposé ici à madame des
biens dans des proportions moindres sans
doute mais montre que souvent dans il
est très rare que du parti sont à armes
égales devant les tribunaux on regarde
les risques gestion des risques et bah
non c'est juste une p'tite madame qui
est seul qui va pouvoir nous faire
beaucoup mais on s'est expliqué qu'une
compagnie peut traiter comme ça
l'inventeur de son produit vedette
personnellement je ne me l'expliqué pas
et généralement une nouvelle fois pour
les raisons de marketing et publicité
vous allez essayer de bien traiter
d'avoir comme de bonnes relations avec
les inventeurs avec les personnes qui
sont à l'origine de vos produits phares
pour éviter toute mauvaise publicité
d'autant plus que ce produit est destiné
aux enfants
et comble de l'affront pour micheline
des biens elle doit désormais acheter en
magasin la pâte à modeler tutti frutti
pour ses petits enfants y revient ils
vont me faire abandonner parce que
encore ma fille ma plus vieille a dit ma
mère
non tu continues alba tu continues il ya
plein mang qui m'encourage qui me disent
michelin non tu te laisses pas avoir dit
que les spas détruit on a maintenant tu
continues atteint
johan et josé il ya eu des
développements dans votre enquête
jusqu'à la toute dernière minute
oui en effet il ya quelques jours le
président ce beau jeu olivier mailloux
nous a écrit pour nous informer qu'il
mette un terme au contrat de monsieur
garros imagine que c'est beaucoup en
lien avec les images que vous lui avez
présenté nous exactement bon est ce
qu'on peut espérer que le procès
commence bientôt
l'avocat de madame des biens espagne en
début de procès fin 2010 ou le début
2019 mais on nous dit qu'il faut plutôt
que de voir un début d'ici deux ans
alors madame des billets devrait
continuer de se battre
wip elle le fait pour ses filles et ses
petits enfants merci beaucoup pour votre
enquête
restez avec nous parce qu'après la pause
on parle de ce pot de vin payés par
snc-lavalin à l'ex grand patron de la
société des ponts
[Musique]